THE PRESIDENT WANT WITH THE
DOCUMENTS IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
WHY DID HE KEEP THEM WHEN THEY
WANTED THEM BACK.
ONE REASON TO BOIL DOWN TO TWO
WORDS, ME AND MINE.
MAGGIE HABERMAN JOINS US NOW.
YOU RAISE A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
EXPLANATIONS BUT YOU RAISE ONE
POSSIBILITY THAT THIS MAY BE
MORE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT --
FORMER PRESIDENT'S PERSONALITY
THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
>> IT COULD BE AND HE WAS
CERTAINLY KNOWN AS SOMEBODY WHO
LIKED TO SHOW THINGS OFF.
HE LIKED TO SHOW OFF --
>> CHATCHKIES.
>> WHEN HE WAS A BUSINESSMAN HE
HAD THEM IN SOME CORNER OF HIS
OFFICE.
SHAQUILLE O'NEAL'S GIANT SHOE HE
WOULD SHOW OFF TO VISITORS.
HE LIKED SHOWING OFF THESE KIM
JONG-UN LETTERS WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE WOULD COME TO THE OFFICE,
REPORTERS, VISITING DIGNITARIES,
YOU NAME IT, AND HE WOULD WAVE
THEM AROUND.
SOME OF THOSE WERE AMONG THE
ITEMS THAT WERE AT MAR-A-LAGO SO
THAT'S ONE POSSIBILITY.
WE KNOW THAT HE WAS TELLING
ADVISERS WHEN HE WAS RESISTING
GIVING THESE THINGS BACK,
"THEY'RE MINE, IT'S MINE" AND SO
FORTH SO THAT'S ONE POSSIBILITY.
THE OTHER IS THAT HE SEES -- ONE
OTHER IS THAT HE SEES SOME
ADVANTAGE AND WHETHER THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES HIM SEEM
AGRAND DIESED OR BIGGER OR
WHETHER HE COULD SEE IT AS
LEVERAGE OF SOME KIND, YOU HAVE
TO CONSIDER THAT POSSIBILITY.
THERE'S A LOT WE STILL DON'T
KNOW.
BUT TRUMP THROUGHOUT HIS
PRESIDENCY ACTED AS IF THERE WAS
NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HIMSELF
AND THE GOVERNMENT AND HIS
COMPANY.
IT WAS ALL ONE BIG BRAND.
>> WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
WHEN I WENT TO HIS APARTMENT TO
INTERVIEW HIM LONG AGO, I WAS
OBSESSED, HE HAD THIS FAKE
RENOIR PAINTING.
THIS IS THE FAKE HE HAD IN HIS
HOUSE AND IT'S A PRETTY BAD FAKE
BECAUSE I PULLED UP THE ORIGINAL
AND I LOOKED AT THE ORIGINAL
RIGHT NEXT TO IT.
BUT HE SWEARS THAT IS THE REAL
ONE.
HE HAS CONTINUED TO PUSH THAT
FOR A LONG TIME.
IS THAT SORT OF IN THAT SAME
VEIN OF LIKE HE JUST LIKES TO
SHOW OFF STUFF THAT HE HAS?
>> YEAH, LOOK, AGAIN, PART OF
THE ME ASPECT OF THIS IS
SELF-AGGRANDIZEMENT.
SO CLAIMING A RENOIR THAT YOU
CAN TELL LOOKING AT THE INTERNET
IS NOT REAL IS PART OF THAT.
>> THESE ARE REAL DOCUMENTS.
>> THESE ARE REAL DOCUMENTS AND
WE DON'T KNOW WHY HE HAD THEM.
WE DO KNOW THAT HE WAS TOLD TO
GIVE THEM BACK REPEATEDLY AND IT
TOOK MANY, MANY MONTHS IN 2021
AND HE FINALLY SENT BACK SOME
BUT NOT ALL.
THERE WAS A MUCH LONGER FIGHT.
I DON'T WANT TO SOUND AS IF
WE'RE MINIMIZING THE POTENTIAL
HARM OR LAW BREAKING OR ANYTHING
ELSE IN SAYING THAT HE SIMPLY
TREATED THIS ALL AS IF IT WAS
ABOUT HIMSELF.
AND THEN WHERE IT WENT FROM
THAT, WE DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU'VE ALSO REPORTED ON HOW
THIS IS EMBLEMATIC OF IN GENERAL
HOW HE DEALT WITH DOCUMENTS.
FLUSHING THEM DOWN THE TOILET,
RIPPING THEM UP.
>> YES.
HE WAS SLOPPY.
THERE WAS -- DOCUMENTS WOULD BE
RIPPED UP.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE
TO GO THROUGH HIS TRASH OR GO
THROUGH THE FLOOR AND TAPE THEM
BACK TOGETHER AND GIVE THEM TO
THE STAFF SECRETARY TO LOOK AT
TO SEE WHETHER THEY HAD TO BE
PRESERVED UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT WHICH EXISTED AFTER
NIXON.
WHEN NIXON WANTED TO LEAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH DOCUMENTS AND
TAPES AND THEN IT BECAME LAW.
TRUMP IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABIDING
BY THAT.
HE NEVER WANTED TO.
HE WOULD TAKE CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL UP TO THE RESIDENCE.
JOHN KELLY TRIED REALLY HARD TO
KEEP HIM FROM DOING THAT.
I THINK THAT SOME OF THOSE
CONSTRAINTS THAT KELLY TRIED
PUTTING IN PLACE, TRUMP
DEFINITELY BRISTLED AT.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME WHAT IT
LOOKED LIKE BY 2020.
>> POLITICALLY, WHAT DOES THE
FORMER PRESIDENT GAIN OR LOSE IF
THE AFFIDAVIT IS RELEASED?
>> IT DEPENDS, ANDERSON, BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN IT.
OBVIOUSLY SEVERAL MEDIA OUTLETS,
INCLUDING MY OWN, HAVE ARGUED
THAT IT SHOULD BE RELEASED.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
ARGUING AGAINST IT.
TRUMP'S FOLKS GAIN MORE BY
SAYING SEE, THEY WON'T UNSEAL
IT.
IF THEY THOUGHT THERE WAS
ADVANTAGE TO THIS, I THINK HE
WOULD BE GETTING INTO THIS FIGHT
HIMSELF.
HIS LAWYERS HAVE NOT FILED
ANYTHING IN THIS CASE.
HIS LAWYER WAS THERE OBSERVING
THE PROCEEDINGS TODAY, BUT IT'S
ALLIES OF TRUMP WHO ARE GOING
ABOUT ARGUING THE SAME CASE AS
THE MEDIA.
I THINK HE SEES MORE ADVANTAGE
IN BEING SEEN AS SOMEBODY BEING
VICTIMIZED.
BECAUSE AS WE SAW WITH THE
WARRANT, WHEN THE WARRANT WAS
UNSEALED, IT WAS NOT GOOD NEWS
FOR TRUMP AS A LOT OF PEOPLE
AROUND HIM HAD BEEN INTIMATING.
IF NOT GOOD NE